si la parole est à monsieur jean
françois lamour surprise la question
s'adresse au premier selon le premier
ministre la vente en bloc du conglomérat
stx pourrait être annoncée dès cette
semaine
précisant ainsi le sort des chantiers
navals de saint nazaire avant même la
décision du tribunal sud-coréen en
charge du dossier
cette décision étant prévue le 11
novembre prochain le néerlandais damen
qui a la préférence du gouvernement
français serait donc de fait écartée au
profit soit d'un croisiéristes chinois
soit peut-être d'un autre candidat dont
on ne connaît pas l'identité
or le devenir des chantiers de saint
nazaire ne met pas seulement en jeu
notre industrie navale civile
il touche aussi à d'autres industries
navales de défense et donc à la
souveraineté de la france
en effet les chantiers de saint nazaire
sont les seuls en europe à disposer des
capacités nécessaires pour construire la
coque du successeur du charles de gaulle
mais égale des prix pétroliers
ravitailleurs la marine nationale
j'étais samedi dernier avec mon oeil à
mon collègue eric woerth à bord du
sous-marin du sud du porte-avions pardon
au large de chypre
je parle bien du porte avions j'ai pu
une nouvelle fois constater le caractère
indispensable de cet outil qui prend
part à la bataille de me saoule ça c'est
plus sérieux à travers l'action des
rafale marine et au delà de cette
projection de puissance permise par le
groupe aéronaval
le porte-avions contribue également au
volet aéroportée de notre dissuasion
nucléaire
monsieur le premier ministre votre
gouvernement a déjà exclu de devenir
actionnaire majoritaire de la société
ect txt d'où ma question aller simple
quelles garanties apportées vous
aujourd'hui pour préserver notre
capacité stratégique à construire le
successeur du charles de gaulle
merci vous colle à part la tam cieux
michel sapin misait économie et des
finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés mais c'est le
député l'amour monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement je le dis très simplement
partage exactement les mêmes
préoccupations qui sont les vôtres
d'abord parce que stx c'est un très beau
chantier un chantier où il ya des
compétences exceptionnelles
un chantier qui il y a quelques années
rencontré de grandes difficultés et qui
aujourd'hui à des carnets de commandes
absolument exceptionnel qui assure son
avenir et donc pour cette raison le
maintien de l'emploi
nous nous battrons tous ensemble pour
faire en sorte que l'avenir de stx soit
3 net clair et précis mais il ya aussi
la préoccupation que vous venez de
décrire qui est celle de défense de nos
intérêts nationaux de notre souveraineté
nationale puisque ces chantiers sont les
seuls capables de construire les très
grandes coque en particulier dans le
domaine militaire auquel vous avez fait
allusion
et c'est donc une des raisons pour
lesquelles là aussi nous feront
prévaloir les intérêts de la france dans
un débat où dans une discussion d'un
dossier aussi difficile que celui ci de
quelles armes disposons-nous de deux
armes vous les connaissez la première
c'est que nous avons un pacte
d'actionnaires puisque nous avons 33 %
un peu plus de 33%
l'état a aujourd'hui la capacité de
s'opposer de s'opposer à la prise de
participations d'actionnaires qui nous
paraît très mauvais pour la continuité
économique et social de cette entreprise
est la deuxième arme dont nous disposons
vous le savez c'est que nous avons la
capacité de défendre les intérêts
nationaux les intérêts fondamentaux les
intérêts stratégiques de la france
on nous opposant à nos opposants en
refusant que un actionnaire qui ne
serait pas qui risquerait de mettre en
cause notre indépendance devienne
propriétaire d'un grand chantier comme
celui ci voilà pourquoi au fond sur ce
sujet comme peut-être sur d'autres nous
pouvons nous battre ensemble pour
défendre l'intérêt de la france
merci monsieur le ministre la parole